so the capital uh skirmish
uh who's
our boy what's his name we just did the
video about the q and on shaman the q
anon shaman are they trying to put him
in the clink for this behavior i believe
they arrested him already yeah i mean he
was pretty out there in the open wasn't
he yeah yeah yeah
yeah jake and jelly lead siege of
catholics by the way this wasn't a coup
everyone's saying this was a coup or a
revolution i mean this was closer to a
high school theater group i mean listen
they they were not they i mean i'm not
excusing what they did right
what they did was [ __ ] insane and
obviously there were laws that they
broke and they will go to jail like and
and by the way that's everybody that
destroys property break breaking and
entering these are all laws that we have
for a reason civil society exists for a
reason okay so if you're breaking those
laws uh for whatever because you think
that you know uh the landlord should all
be taken out and hung
that's that's breaking a law and if you
break the law because you think that
inside of uh congress there's a chamber
with children that nancy pelosi is
eating you're breaking a law either way
you're breaking a law so you know sorry
to everybody who's like but i i like one
kind of riot that's the maturity of this
country everybody's sitting behind
screens being like well this violent
protest was not good i like that kind i
like this type of chaos it's like people
sitting in a restaurant being like
i enjoy this type of chaos oh you like
that chaos
i like this chaos ah interesting just
people tasting wine
a sommelier comes over the sommelier of
like you know the apocalypse and he's
like what do you like
what do you like do you like a racial
equity narrative with some burned
buildings and some chase please or would
you like a proto-fascist takeover
involving a horned gentleman
leading a group of people
up the steps of congress and people like
hmm they both sound
appealing it's stupid you cannot
encourage this type of behavior at all
very funny though you know it's funny q
anon shaman known as 33 year old jake
angeli of phoenix man phoenix huh
has been a fixture at a number of
pro-trump rallies and protests across
2020 especially in his home state soon
after q anon shaman received viral
infamy some followers of the loose
collective of conspiracy theorists
movement began to turn on him falsely
suggesting angeli is actually antifa and
had infiltrated the mob ain't that
always the way
man what a short rise right
ain't that always the way
it's like this it's like i'm in the
movement i'm in the movement queuing on
queueing on queueing on shaman queueing
on shaman viral viral big antifa
a big circle
it's almost like the people that get
involved in these things aren't the most
stable
and they'll actually turn on anyone
interesting
it's like the underpinnings of these
movements are not logical coherent
political beliefs
uh it's really the majority of it is
undiagnosed and diagnosed mental illness
many of these people have been diagnosed
by the way i wanted to correct uh kansas
owens when she said it's undiagnosed
mental illness i'm like many a lot of
it's diagnosed
somebody tweets why aren't these quote
crisis actors more successful in acting
this guy was way into the role much
earlier clearly a method actor he's
really selling it he should be alongside
de niro
is this the one where he's yelling let's
see what this is this is a crazy
conspiracy theorist he also people
getting covetes in arizona i think this
is our boy jake angeli all right
it's [ __ ] crazy you guys
the amount of people that believe this
[ __ ] is insane interesting
this just goes to show the mockingbird
media
the way it uses fear to compartmentalize
to propagandize
and divide and conquer our country this
whole country is an episode of the
x-files
[Applause]
the virus
cannot survive arizona's heat
by the way stop this
i know like 30 comics that are that are
five minutes away from this behavior if
they don't get it special
i know 30 to 50 people that are five
minutes away from horns and screaming in
a parking lot if something doesn't turn
around if you don't let them go perform
somewhere
this is a scientific fact
the corrupt media
is lying to you
your corrupt governments
dick ducey
this [ __ ] lie to you
grove in 1984
is a globalist
propaganda hoax i love all the people
that are like kova's the global the big
global reset it's like what reset it's
been going the way it's been going for
50 years
what reason there's no reset it's this
i'll tell you this no more i can't tell
he's just talking it's annoying with the
screaming
it's annoying
um but yeah that's jake and jelly
i mean these these people again you know
i don't i've never known someone you
know i i guess i've i've witnessed
people that have gone really radical uh
in their belief systems uh not quite to
that extent where it's like costume shop
radical but i've known people that have
gone really off the reservation um
the one thing that seems to unite all of
them is that number one they started to
get attention doing it it was what got
them attention so they would never stop
because it was the only way they got
attention they didn't get attention
other ways they weren't they didn't get
attention from their talent and they
didn't get attention uh from uh you know
any you know interpersonal thing that
was good going on in their life
they got a tension by
going
crazy publicly in front of people
you know this is what
they you know enjoy doing and i don't
mean and i don't just mean whitney but
there are people kidding she's her dog
she called me her dog ate her hand or
something it's fine
but i've i've seen people politically go
off the radar go off the rails like this
and they're off the reservation i know
that's not a kosher term to say but this
is what happens they you know
you know you're yelling in a parking lot
with a [ __ ] with viking horns on
you're not it's not going well
so i don't know what this got but this
guy's gonna see some real jail time
probably you know probably i mean this
is a real embarrassing end for the q
movement i thought it would kind of
silently
kind of just
go away
like like a tide goes out like a tide
comes in and the tide goes out this one
was rough this one was a little
embarrassing
for the q movement this was rough i
don't know what the hell they thought
was going to happen they were going to
get in there and the u.s military was
going to go you're right let's go
and then jake angeli is the president
yeah what did you think it's the same
thing with a black lives matter what did
you think was going to happen just the
national guard's gonna stand down you're
gonna take over portland i mean i don't
know
but now of course we have uh you know
the the this very schizophrenic body
politic where you can't keep up with
everything you can't even understand
you're like okay
you're like these people gathered
in front of government buildings and
they harass the police who are heroes
[Laughter]
and you're like staring at these people
like what
wait a minute what and there and then
they find all the black lives matter
protests that were always peaceful like
nothing yes like because we all know the
riots we were watching had nothing to do
with the protest i mean they had nothing
to do with that and they didn't happen
most of the riots didn't have that you
saw with your own eyes the burning of
businesses the burning of cop cars the
looting of stores that didn't happen and
if it did happen it was justified
that didn't happen you saw it i i
brought it up i people are angry at me
because i've literally people hate me
because i've literally said things i've
seen with my eyes
[Laughter]
that has label people are angry with me
because of i'm a chill and right wing
and alt-right or whatever because i've
just uh i've been sitting in front of a
tv
huh
okay i'm seeing a thing and now i'm
saying what i'm seeing
and people have gotten angry about that
you know
getting angry i get it
i have enemies people dislike me because
i've literally just said what i've seen
so when you say what you've seen
uh people get angry they're worse than
people uh that were uh knuckleheads
in all these movements that seem to just
wanna you know benefit themselves in in
you know do crazy things these are like
people
these were like dorks and i'm not again
um people are gonna be like they're
terrorists sure
sure but
also let's not glorify them
uh
by by making them out to be more than
what they are they were willing to do
some very stupid things which they'll
pay for but they're idiots i mean
they're not the terrorists are always
smart but like
these people believe in a fairy tale
their door i mean some of them are like
elderly you see that old woman you see
the photo of her
i'm going to compare her to like a like
a terrorist to like the woman's got
dementia she's wandering around the
capitol she doesn't even know what's
going on
you know what i mean
this is a crazy
woman whose prescription medication is
all
messed up and she's she's wandering
around
the capitol the woman that got mace too
yeah yeah you know i mean and then
there's a woman that got amazed
let's play her
she's like i love how nonchalantly she
goes it's a revolution they're like what
are you doing here she goes uh it's a
revolution tummy
what do you think i'm doing here we go
ma'am fun what happened to you fun
couple alert i got an ace
yeah
by the police
you know by the way stop that and what
happened
she was getting maced and her man was
like
that's you know
he's kind of unbothered he's he's
completely unaffected
she's just got mace in the face he's he
go you know in the ride home he looks at
her and goes you got a little excited
he got a little excited and she goes
well it was a revolution because i know
i know
i know
but you got a little excited and she's
like they didn't mace you and he goes
why you know you went nuts
you went you tried to jump on that cop's
back
she goes well it was a coup it was a
revolution you don't like anything i do
you never support me
if this woman could get a small business
loan to be a caterer would she be doing
this
yeah i made it like a foot inside and
they pushed me out and they maced me
what's your name what's your name where
are you from my name is elizabeth i'm
from knoxville tennessee and why did you
want to go in we're storming the capitol
it's a revolution
we're storming the capital it's a
revolution dummy
are you dumb
we're storming the capitals these people
just want to have fun i mean i think
it's time we open up dave and busters
we've gone too long
this didn't work this whole experiment
where americans didn't work doesn't work
let's take note
this doesn't seem to produce good
results okay
so i don't care what the next thing is i
don't care if it's the black plague i
don't care if it's ebola hemorrhagic
fever bleeding through the eyes when you
close down fuddruckers and dave and
busters and applebees and fridays and
two for one margarita night at chili's
it ends a few months later with a guy in
horns standing in the middle of the
capital
that's where it ends
so think long and hard about that gavin
newsom think long and hard about where
this is gonna end
it's really crazy but the country is not
built
to do anything except work sadly it's
just what we're built to do
it's what we're built to do we are built
to just run at 100 miles an hour and
work and work and work and if we don't
do it it becomes a real problem and then
you get this and then you get this woman
who's looks like kind of a normal
suburban lady kind of yeah and i'm not
saying that because she's white i'm
saying that cause she doesn't have blue
hair and
face tattoos and nose rings she looks
kind of like whatever i mean she's got a
piano scarf is that a piano scarf maybe
not i'm straight no it's just striped uh
i don't love that but this this looks
like someone's substitute teacher and
she's getting maced while she runs into
the capital i mean wow
you gotta hand it to trump though he
knows how to sell a product he really
does
i mean you know he knows how to
celebrate you know he's walking around
looking at the tv
uh going live because i spoke to
somebody who made a good point um and
they were like they were like yeah he's
just walking around going good good this
is good very happy oh yeah because he
wants he wants people to know that he
can he could [ __ ] he could cause
loracus
and he's not going to be a bind's
inauguration he's going to be out of
there let's play our video which is very
funny please of course if you have not
seen this uh you should see this this is
an interview with uh jake and jelly and
we get to the bottom of of what jake and
jelly's really all about
i'm sorry things got out of hand okay
this everything people are saying about
me isn't true i'm an actor i'm a voice
actor i'm a musician stop the steel
what people saw yesterday was me doing
vocal exercises
me just kind of you know putting myself
out there for the first time the
industry just doesn't want a white male
unless they're literally storming the
capital you know obviously save the
children and and do a coup but also you
know as important or even more important
is to just try to like you know build my
socials this is my american idol this is
my the voice i think there is a hole in
the market for sort of this like
reactionary psychopath
that's also very musical when i first
started working with q i thought q mac
quincy jones people said to me what was
yesterday was it a revolution was it a
coup
uh it was an exercise in branding we
have no problem with the capitol police
by the way we have no problem they were
nice to us we took selfies with them
they let us in
uh you know we met a lot of them on
4chan sometimes i'm sad
and i feel like
there's not a space for men to share
their feelings
in this country
and i think that's tragic i'm willing to
learn and grow i've been reading a lot
of tweets about my behavior that are
making a lot of sense to me i'm going
like back in my childhood and i'm going
yeah
yeah that was it
yeah that was it it's okay if i like the
show shrill
on hulu it's my favorite show
and i can admit that like i like it
because it's a big
powerful woman that's confident and that
makes me happy
i'm the victim
yeah ridiculous by the way everyone's
like how did you get the costume so
how did you get the costume so quickly
ben avery went to the costume shop ben
avery really whipped that up shout out
to jones fabric yeah combination of
everything
joanne's fabric what'd i say jones oh my
bad
we'll now do it the right way joanne's
shout out to joanne's fabric in vegas is
[ __ ] he he acts like a petulant child
now he won't do it he's like yeah
um